[Música]
llegamos a revistas de prensa aquí en
nuestro programa directo américa para
llegar hasta en el estudio rosa pérez
masdéu rosa bienvenida a feliz inicio de
semana feliz el lunes dedicamos entonces
rosa esta revista de prensa a hacer un
repaso de las coberturas nacionales e
internacionales de lo que fueron
entonces las elecciones que se deberán
ayer en chile y también en venezuela
pero empecemos por las presidenciales
chilenas que medios vamos a repasar rosa
buenos días raúl exacto empieza fuerte
la semana y va a ser un mes bien cargado
al menos en chile hasta la segunda
vuelta de estas presidenciales hemos
querido seleccionar en términos de
prensa internacional the gardian al
yazira y el 'new york times' para ver
distintos puntos de vista respecto a los
resultados de ayer entonces rosa the
gardian adice populista populista de
extrema derecha y ex líder de protestas
listos ya para la segunda vuelta a estas
elecciones presidenciales en chile que
van a ser el 19 de diciembre exacto como
vemos la prensa internacional sigue un
poco en la fase de presentación de los
candidatos que se van a disputar la
presidencia no chilena por un lado the
gardian define a jose antonio kast como
para los lectores británicos no
recordemos para introducir un poco estos
candidatos como candidato del partido
republicano de extrema derecha católico
devoto padre de nuevo hijos de nueve
hijos que se opone al matrimonio
igualitario al aborto y a la corrección
política por otro lado señala que cast
ha hecho campaña basándose en argumentos
de reforzar la seguridad pública y los
valores conservadores mientras que en el
otro punto del abanico político se
encuentra el izquierdista gabriel boric
que en este medio británico define como
ex líder del movimiento estudiantil
defensor de las libertades sociales y de
la recuperación económica basada en una
economía verde no para salir de la
crisis que nos ha dejado la pandemia y
también según este medio británico y
según bueno un poco toda la opinión
internacional lo interesante va a ser a
qué candidatos apoyan el resto de los
candidatos que no van a pasar a la
segunda vuelta seguimos con nuestra
ronda de medios internacionales
en chile con al yazira que está acá de
cara a una segunda vuelta en chile
mientras el ultraderechista casi lidera
el voto presidencial exacto seguimos en
lo mismo no también al yazira plantea un
poco los dos polos ella de lo que va a
ser la segunda vuelta de la presidencial
dice que van a ser los comicios más
polarizados desde la restauración
democrática en chile tras la dictadura
de pinochet y señala que se establece
una clara división entre los votantes
que buscan una reforma del modelo de
libre mercado y los que reclaman una
línea más dura contra el crimen y la
inmigración destaca que cast reivindica
este legado neoliberal de pinochet y que
ha sido comparado con donald trump o con
jair bolsonaro mientras que boris dice
que aumentará los impuestos a los súper
ricos que quiere también ampliar las
prestaciones de servicios sociales
proteger las comunidades indígenas y
también al medio ambiente y según los
corresponsales de al yazira ayer en las
sedes de la campaña de cast y en la de
boric pues se respiraba en ambos a 2 un
fuerte ambiente de euforia el 'new york
times'
jose antonio kast candidato de la
extrema derecha lidera la primera vuelta
a las elecciones en chile vamos a ver
entonces que amplía el 'new york times'
con usted rosa el 'new york times'
señala que resulta sorprendente que el
pueblo chileno haya apoyado a una opción
de extrema derecha teniendo en cuenta lo
sacudido que está el país por las
protestas sociales la desigualdad y el
aumento del coste de vida no señale
señala que ambas opciones son dos formas
muy distintas de abordar el momento que
está viviendo este país andino y
recuerda un poco el contexto en el que
se da esta elección y es el estallido
social de 2019 que llevó recordemos a la
convención constitucional que está
redactando la nueva carta magna del país
por otro lado la crisis está económica
agravada por la pandemia la acusación
constitucional contra piñera raúl pues
todo todo este seguido de factores
sociales que han marcado mucho la
campaña electoral así es rosa y además
como usted lo decía esa redacción de la
constitución y la implementación de la
constitución tocar a este próximo
presidente ahora vamos a ver como titula
la prensa nacional chilena empezamos con
una tercera tras lograr la primera
mayoría en la primera vuelta cast hace
gestos de adherentes de parís y también
provost exacto ya la prensa chilena es
se centra más en lo que va a suceder a
lo largo de este mes no porque esta
prensa ya destinada a la población
chilena no le hace falta recordar cuáles
son los perfiles de cada candidato los
chilenos saben de sobras quienes
castilla quienes boric por lo que la
tercera dice a ver a quién va a apoyar
pues sobre todo parís y diesel y provost
y por un lado recuerda que parecía este
candidato que ha hecho campaña en su
totalidad desde estados unidos
prácticamente es sin pisar chile pues no
comparte muchos puntos en común sobre
todo en la línea económica con casas con
el ultraderechista el presidente del
partido republicano por otro lado
sebastián sin ser el candidato del
oficialismo pues raúl hay pocas opciones
de que acabe apoyando al izquierdista
boric y por último provoste la candidata
d
así que pues tiene más números de acabar
apoyando a bórico porque ya ha comentado
que nunca podría ser neutral frente al
espíritu fascista que cast representa el
desconcierto los aportes de los grandes
grupos económicos de las candidaturas
presidenciales rosa mira hemos querido
señalar para ver un punto distinto en
estas elecciones y en este artículo
pueden encontrar cuáles han sido los
principales
financiamientos privados de arte de cara
a cada una de las candidaturas sólo para
recordar la de jose antonio kast ha sido
sobre todo financiada tal y como comenta
este texto por miembros de juntas
directivas entre otras cosas de bancos y
grandes compañías pues internación vamos
a hablar ahora de venezuela rosa vamos
con un análisis comparativo de ambos
comicios los chilenos y los venezolanos
con el medio argentino página/12 exacto
mira este medio argentino en dos líneas
dice que son dos mensajes muy distintos
los los que envían cada uno de estos
comicios por un lado en venezuela un
éxito extraordinario del gobierno del
gobierno bolivariano mientras que en
chile la incertidumbre generada por la
performance electoral de la extrema
derecha
espesas dudas sobre la viabilidad de la
reforma constitucional y rápidamente
para cerrar que dice la universal un
periódico venezolano
exacto desde el nacional raúl comenta
pues una muy baja participación no llega
al 42 por ciento en venezuela donde el
oficialismo se lleva 20 de las 23
gobernaciones en unas elecciones como
comentabas donde ha vuelto a participar
la oposición tras tres años de boicot